today we will talk about Jorge Jorge is
a millennial he is one of us and he's
about to graduate from University and
join the workforce but he s slightly or
some people say huge differences in
expectations values and priorities
around work and he is actually very
worried about the stereotypes that other
generations have about Millennials and
himself may affect his career so Jorge
he or he doesn't want a routine boring
job he doesn't want to miss his kids
soccer practice he wants a job that
continuously challenges him presents new
learning opportunity and one that lets
him balance his working life have a
schedule that's flexible to him but he's
worried that he may get stereotyped as
lazy Jorge got the best education that
has ever been able to humanity so far he
adapts very quickly to new situations
he drives in rapidly changing
environments he does not shy away from
taking initiative and he's not shy away
he doesn't shy away to jump on new
opportunities when he finds a new job or
a new organization but he's worried that
he might get stereotyped as disloyal and
Jorge is also born as a native
technology user he's very quick at
adapting new technologies
he's a very avid social network user he
blogs he posts his thoughts on Facebook
he shares photographs on Instagram and
even sometimes he shares his Southeast
and this actually makes him a great
visual thinker and he is like super
efficient in in for processing
technology and information compared to
previous generation but he's worried
that he might get labeled and
stereotyped as narcissistic so going
into the workforce poor he's very
worried he doesn't know what to do and
many of us here we are all Millennials
we are about to graduate many I believe
many of us share the same concerns and
luckily we are here today to talk to you
about what are the common stereotypes
why the other generations have those
thoughts about us and how we can use
strategic communication to tackle these
challenges and how we can try and the
first one as I mentioned the stereotype
is around laziness and Krista will talk
to you about that
when I wander into the kitchen in the
morning at least one morning a week this
is the site that greets me my roommate
Jason is not Tom Cruise but he will be
wearing a button-up shirt sometimes a
tie and definitely no pants
Jason is a millennial and he works at
Google and he flat out refuses to get to
work before 11:00 a.m. as a result if
someone schedules a morning meeting
Jason will participate via Google
hangout so he can engage in the meeting
and have the added benefit of no pants
required its practices like this such as
getting in late that have led to the
stereotype that Millennials are lazy now
we know the simply adventure we all
worked really hard to get here but
Millennials do demand a certain
flexibility in the workplace for example
Millennials resist specialization for
fear it will lock us into an inflexible
career track we also tend to define
career success in terms of personal
fulfillment instead of climbing some
corporate ladder now a lot of
corporations are still dealing with how
to incorporate these into the corporate
structure but I'm gonna give you some
techniques so that you can combat this
stereotype while still maintaining the
flexibility that a lot of a lot of us
want so first if you're lucky enough to
be able to have a flexible work schedule
it's important to clearly communicate
those hours with your supervisor and
your colleagues
this shows that it wasn't just that you
missed your alarm this morning and
Roli you made a conscious decision that
this is the lifestyle that's important
to you when you are at work it's
important to have face-to-face contact
so that you're not always that based on
the computer screen or the the text
through the phone if your supervisor is
hesitant to allow you to work flexible
hours consider that maybe they're
uncomfortable with or unfamiliar with
the technology that allows these
flexible work hours to be possible and
may benefit you to help your boss become
more comfortable with this technology
and finally find common ground it turns
out that boomers and Millennials are
actually very well aligned in our
workplace preferences and career goals
so you probably have more in common with
your supervisor than you think so now
that your boss no longer thinks that
you're a lazy bum let's deal with the
issue of Millennials not being loyal to
the workplace so as Chris just said it's
important for Millennials to seek out
mentorship and defined allies among
older generations but this could be
difficult if your supervisor perceives
you as disloyal or doesn't think you'll
be around for very long and so you see
older generations tend to see
Millennials as being like hummingbirds
we flit around from job to job
experience to experience without staying
in one place for long enough before
moving on to the next exciting
opportunity so I'm going to show you
three different strategies to cope with
this stereotype and to beat the
hummingbird stereotype so you can
receive the mentorship and build the
allies that you need the first one of
those is simply to communicate what will
make you loyal as we've heard our
generation often values things
differently than the older generations
we tend to value job flexibility over a
little bit more salary we value
challenges and new experiences over job
titles
and these sorts of things might not be
what your supervisor expects and so you
need to clearly communicate these values
and show them that you can be loyal
perhaps just to different things so
let's say you fail to communicate or
convince them that you can be loyal in
that case you need to at least show them
that you can be valuable and the easiest
and simplest way to do that is simply to
provide your value now focus on what you
can do immediately the short-term
benefits that you can have to the
company it's just important that you do
that in such a way that doesn't limit
your long-term potential for growth
finally if all else fails it may be best
to simply accept your suppose that
disloyalty embrace it say reframe it
show them that you are adaptable and
that you thrive in changing environments
all right so we've shown you how you can
beat the stereotypes of disloyalty and
laziness so now let's take a look at how
you can deal with the challenges that
are that associate our generation with
technology
that's I'd like to discuss another
stereotype people have about millenniums
that is our interaction with technology
can't believe that 64% of public
actually believe that there's a huge gap
between millenniums and outer generation
in their way of interaction with
technology the gap is even bigger than
their differences in moral values
actually reverse races and ethnicities
and the importance of family
well millennium generation is a
generation of digital natives when talk
about millenniums people just email and
think of social networks photo sharing
cell phones and Internet it is true
social networks are the building blocks
of social interaction of generation a
millennium generation among 2013
Facebook users millenniums on average
have 250 friends while in contrast this
number for the elder boomers was just a
15 millenniums also led away on followed
photo sharing so much that oxford world
of year into 2013 was surfing
millenniums are also more likely than
any other generation to say that it is
ok to use cell phone in class in lecture
or at a dining table and people
criticize millenniums all the time that
we spend so much time on internet and we
read 5 fewer books when their days are
rather be available answer dear
millenniums just lacked motivation to
seek for a more last one so does that
mean millenniums can just accept all the
blames
and criticisms no because the key of
communication as in understanding where
your audience are from and communicating
the advantage communicating message in
their names are we using Internet too
much frequently yes but our current
fast-paced business arena requires this
kind of immediacy including the
abilities to retrieve and process the
information far more quickly than our
previous generation and millenniums have
developed this kind of unique
capabilities that help us to contrivance
ask information as reader thinkers do we
share too much maybe but we are creating
the online content 59% of teams have
their blogs and create all my contents
millenniums generation are just assuring
our earlier preference for using
technology to capture synthesize and
express their thoughts opinions and
experiences are we too narcissistic yeah
maybe but remember more and more
companies are using the millenniums
proclivities to the advantage they are
encouraging the new hires to actively
engage in internal social networks they
see minions as Co developers in product
marketing and designing and more and
more millennium consumers actively
engage and participate in the creation
of consumer goods so as long as we
understand where our unique values are
we are able to convert our disadvantages
to our advantages
and such such king is going to give you
the conclusion for how to leverage the
communication to beat people stereotypes
of Romanians the coming back to forehead
so the sad news is these stereotypes do
exist they are far more common than we
would like them to be but the good news
is we can tackle them with the previous
generations they don't want us to fail I
mean they made us they were our parents
they were our teachers they were our
mentors they want us to succeed
it's just that they grew up in a
different world they have different
values priorities and expectations and
using strategy communication can easily
tackle those challenges this will make
sure that we not only survive the
workplace but also tribe there and also
build stronger relationships with them
this is a very limited time to tackle
all those challenges and we try to
mention the top three most common ones
and how you can challenge them and how
you can tackle them but I'm sure many of
you have questions in this heated topic
which is very important for us going
forward